this is the disney star guitarist yes it
is what it looks like finally a guitar
that you can plug into a computer and
play a guitar hero like game without
pressing silly plastic buttons is that
what this really is exactly right now
you can play a real guitar play a video
game and learn songs learn how to play
the guitar so it's not just about the
competition there's also a learning
aspect it's learning but there is a
competition in that we're playing a
video game so we're scoring points and
you know that sets in you want to get
the high score you at some point you
want to post it may be online you have
the high score so there is that video
game competitive element definitely well
I've heard of at least one other person
that's working on this because it's kind
of a holy grail you know the ability to
play a guitar you know as in guitar hero
or something like it how did you pull
this off and why was nobody else that
I've talked to over the last couple
months able to do it before you I mean
this is really really cool us music work
has certain new patents on a digital
guitar interface and we were able to use
that technology and partner with Disney
and create this game so that's how we're
pulling it off there's a we were able to
keep the price down keep the latency
down which means you're you're tracking
of your guitar you hit the guitar you
want to hear the note that's always been
a big conundrum in this field so we were
able to conquer that and have a real
life experience with the real guitar
very nice so when people get this game
you know when it eventually comes out or
this learning tool whatever whichever
way it goes what will they what will
they use for a guitar will they use
their own guitar and these strings or
how will that work you can use your own
guitar in the strings what we're showing
you today is that with the software
package you will get a Disney guitar
made by washburn aimed at the tween
market so it's a three quarter scale
this is the guitar you get with the
software package
also get the colored strings which is
integral in playing the game and helping
certain people visualize a guitar the
guitar as as in and of itself plays like
a guitar so you don't have to be plugged
into the guitar yeah um so is the hope
hear that you know couch potatoes and
plastic button pushers that maybe have
dreamed of taking the stage do you think
this will help them attain that dream oh
definitely you've got you got the guitar
hero video gamers you've got real
guitars we're gonna be the bridge for
that you know you embrace this
technology but when you think about it
if you put all the time countless hours
into playing guitar hero and you get to
be expert level and you're a master of
guitar hero what do you have right no
that one's you have nothing you have
nothing no life right you have nothing
really with this you can put the time in
it and you'll have some tangible
tangible real life experience musical
experience on the guitar you able able
to use and enjoy for the rest of your
life it'll make parents happy as well so
this teaches an actual real-life analog
skill through digital technology exactly
exactly yeah it's a great way of putting
it so this comes out this summer for how
much again it'll come out this summer
for two hundred dollars and it will be
available for both PC and Mac PC and Mac
on the first revision that's incredible
exactly very nice